une séance de culture physique pour les
joueuses de chambray-lès-tours depuis
peu ces professionnels portent les
couleurs d'une entreprise locale sous
leurs vestes des nouvelles brassière des
brassières sur mesure je me sens
vraiment enfin bien maintenu et vu que
là on est un sport de contact entre beau
combat vraiment au niveau du monde
champions maintient tout ça bah on sent
pas une petite gêne à laquelle on va
penser à un moment donc on n'y pense pas
non non j'ai opté pour cela parce que
elle est plutôt bas bien y'a pas de
sartre chose qui me dérangerait elle
nous tient vraiment donc moi j'ai opté
pour celle là oui j'ai choisi les coûts
là elles sont quand même étudié pour
être parfaitement placé à notre poitrine
et du coup elle apporte surtout un
soutien maximal quoi on n'a pas la
sensation d'être gêné par une brassière
qui parfois nous tiens pas à quelques
kilomètres de là voici l'entreprise qui
conçoit les fameuses brassière les
joueuses de handball sont venus ici dans
cet espace c'est un oui dans notre usine
c'est une salle dédiée à la prise de
mesures et aux essayages
c'est à dire que grâce à ce maître ruban
on prend les mesures des sportifs par
exemple les juges lui s'était achevée
pour déterminer leur taille de soutien
gorge de sport et ainsi à peuvent
essayer la brassière qui qui leur
convient des brassières sur mesure un
produit innovant imaginer un jour par
cette entreprise familiale
c'est venu en fait de notre société mère
clé médical z qui fabrique des soutiens
gorge pour les chirurgies plastiques et
on a des chirurgiens plasticiens qui
était à la commission médicale du comité
olympique et qui nous ont demandé de
venir présenter nos produits aux
sportifs comme ça fonctionne et on a
créé la division sports les brassières
sont assemblés dans ce vaste atelier ici
à l'atelier les filles prennent le temps
de faire du montage pièce par pièce
ça nous permet de voir exactement
quelles sont les difficultés aussi du
montage ensuite on repart sur des
essayages avec des sportives qui courent
ou qui font même du hand avec eux
s'étaient achevés et ont fait deux trois
aller retour avant le produit final qui
sera à lui produit à l'extérieur s'est
produit en tunisie
mais avant d'en arriver là la brassière
et imaginer ici
adeline et styliste elle dessine elle
même se produit au niveau de la création
ça va être bien les couleurs tendances
je vais aussi souvent mais comme je
viens de la corse est de la corseterie
je regarde beaucoup si la lingerie
je nourris un peu de plein de choses en
fait à la fois et puis ensuite je vais
faire une proposition à la direction et
ensuite on va va sélectionner le produit
les brassières de saint-avertin sont
commercialisés par des grandes enseignes
dédiées au sport prix moyen entre 45 et
60 2 euros